[Música]
soy brasilero no soy de venezuela
no eso no fue un chiste él no lo dijo
pero siempre que me presenta me gusta
ver al público porque dice no ya le voy
a presentar un mago internacional
comediante y todo hay de dónde será
luego pero venezuela que picado es
no hay que ser así voy a hacer magia
cuando a mí me invitaron a esta charla a
hacer un télex yo dije que les hago lo
primero que pensé bueno voy a hacer algo
intelectual que protección público
intelectual algo que vayan todos los
razonamientos lógicos y para eso bueno y
está que me ayude una persona
inteligente por ejemplo puede ser
tú cómo te llamas
cómo
la wines de dónde eres infancia habla de
español habla un poquito más o menos
hablaba un poquito bien bueno la hoja es
tú tienes pinta de que conoces a alguien
inteligente sabes no tú tienes pinta de
inter me quiera ayudar una plancha
probablemente laboralmente
con ella
a mí me dieron que se suban por allá
porque aquí están las letras se pueden
tropezar y nuestro amigo chávez nos dijo
que había que cuidar la vida éste el
único contexto en que van a oír a un
venezolano diciendo mi amigo chávez es
ahora
bien oye qué alto eres muy bien
mi madre no conteste los santos y el
cuidado con los reflectores cuidado
voy a intentar saber reconocer las
cartas de póker además se llama francesa
la balada francesa sabe mezclar mezcla
lo mejor que puedas nuestra experticia
eso no esto es perdiz y eso es tu
desperdicies esto eso bien yo le voy a
poner condiciones a esto para que sea
imposible que ustedes primera condición
el mezcla no parece mezclar la hora de
jabones pm con mezclas de rey y yo voy a
ponerme incluso más condiciones voy a
hacerlo para que ustedes digan no pues
que no puede ser primera condición
mezcla mezcla segunda condición fuego a
ya lo quitaron
entonces no no fuego no
primera condición tu mezcla mezcla y a
mí me da igual la que avisar esta es la
audiencia así que da lo mismo
vamos nos vamos al lado mezcla bien así
que se mezclan una vez con otra si bien
mezclado lo mejor que puedas bien dawes
ahora y con miral ahora en igual que yo
pongo así diferente al público así a ver
en él
[Música]
muy bien
aquí se señala un poquito de sala para
verlo a todo un poquito eso señala quien
tú quieras tú decides a quien tú quieras
a alguien
señala lo que dices tu persona
ok tiene que ser un poco más específico
porque hay mucha gente allá no pero si
no no no desde el supuesto asiento me va
ayudar
me estoy cansando la cabeza al volante
porque estaba muy alto la persona la
persona con la camisa azul cual el señor
el señor de allá
sabes quién eres levanta la mano señor
de la camisa azul hay como cinco de la
camisa en sus cuales el que levantó a
los cuales no estás tú cómo te llamas
[Aplausos]
cuál prefiere azul o rojo
a sus buques mira la magia va a pasar
aquí lo que tú hagas tú te vas a perder
todo el show pero lo importante es que
tu vista no salga de aquí está bien
preparado recuerda que mezclamos la
balada recuerda que ok cuida por ahí la
web o si quiere tenerla aquí de ley y
paradito ahí
pero vigila vigila
no pierdas de vista las damas como el
señor de sus vidas sabes cuántas cartas
en una vara de póquer
5 aire mentira habla por aquí sale la
voz por la impresionante no sé cómo lo
hace pero muy bien debería ser una
charla que explicarnos cómo dime el
número entre el 1 y el 52
él se lo toma muy en serio francés al
fin siempre con su dime
entre lunes 52 así el más alto que
pudiste 47 4 y 7 puntos 47 el 12 no te
gustaba un poquito más
seguro o quieres cambiar o te quedas con
47 seguro señala tú mismo te señala
alguien incluso no vaya más allá más
atrás alguien que esté por ahí el que tú
quieras
hoy
cuál pero tienes específico es que no
describe lo de alguna manera
es de camiseta negra que está en la
esquina mira cual eres te sabes quién
eres levanta la mano cómo te llamas
cómo te llamas patri muy
yo voy a hacer así tú me dices ya cuando
quieres que me tengas está bien no me
digas ya cuando quiera que me tenga
porque es muy largo y no sé cuándo
detenerme y sacar tus diez y ya nada más
también y tu misión no mira deja de ver
hay un momento ahora mírame a mí
mírame a mí a mí
pero no no yo no hace el color a
distancia mira y asegúrate que yo no voy
a para que tú me ves a los ojos y tú ves
para acá y me dice ya y tú a mí que yo
no vea y tú para acá y para allá para
acá también para cada pareja también le
dice ya a dormir a mí no me dejes de ver
a mí que yo no vea tú ya te dice ya vale
tu me dice voy
zhang a la vez la voy a enseñar lo que
importa no importa no importa no quiero
que haya dudas la saco es la que tú
sacaste ahí hay una cámara por favor una
cámara para enseñarle a la cámara donde
está el cámara y está lista yo le enseño
yo diseño la venta 2
ya yo me voltear porque no quiero que
piense que yo me valgo perfecto
muy bien
[Aplausos]
tuviste un número que fue
pero no saben para qué verdad y tú
elegiste el 7 de trébol y una vara
mezclada pero no sabes para qué y tú
estaba visitando eso pero no sabes para
que yo voy a intentar lo imposible que
el 7 de trébol de esa baraja se coloque
en la posición número 47 esto ahora será
imposible porque lo mezclamos yo le
tocado verdad ahora bien en la trampa lo
digo por si ven algo raro
toda la baraja sacarla del estuche
sácala asegúrate que no quede ningún
adentro
eso es todo en el estuche y el estuche
el estuche son las cartas y vas a contar
aquí hasta 47 un número porque el
desgraciado dijo que vamos con 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20
horas así de rápido en todo espera calma
21 21 21 92 23 24 25 26 27 28 29 30 31
32 33 34 35 36 37 38 39 40 41 42 43 44
45 46 para paralizar esa en el número 47
yo no toca de verdad duele y te mira si
hubieras dicho 46 te hubiera cambiado
periodista 47 no quisiste cambiar de
opinión si la carta número 47 resulta
ser el 73 de trevélez porque yo así lo
digo yo soy inclusivo
7 de tréboles a cabo si esto es de nadie
nos desnudamos pasamos a bailar
a todo lo que hay en la escena y escena
en la carta número 47 señoras y señores
[Música]
y voy a hacer otro porque como no había
nadie desnudo me preocupé
entonces
tú me ayudas tú me ayudas con una
predicción que yo tengo aquí
aquí en este lado mejor así
aquí tengo una predicción
esto es mi predicción sabes como yo sé
que es una predicción porque quisiera la
predicción no tienen
lo que vamos a hacer es que tú le vas a
agarrar así es como se sostienen las
predicciones así así así no te recuperas
la cara
o séase tu caso si puede ser no no no
tengo la cara es muy difícil porque lo
que tengo además otro sobre y un libro
un libro se llama este libro que se
llama decameron de giovanni boccaccio un
libro cualquier y un sobre que tengo
algo especial aquí que tú no puedes ver
pero tú si vas a entrar en un trance
especial cuando yo te lo enseña está
bien yo te enseño algo aquí tú entras en
trance y estás todos listos preparados
está en trance si no es tanto el saber
como otra vez
preparado yo me voy a bajar por aquí
porque a mí sí me gusta el peligro vamos
ayudame cámara sígueme pero sígueme por
el otro lado porque no tienes que ver
como tú viniste con él también es
francesa no entonces no me sirve te
necesito a un francés no sabe leer no
prueba pese a que me puse acuerdo con él
a hola cómo estás puesto como tenemos
como m
m m
saben leer es importante porque necesito
mirar que tiene momento señala alguien
que tú quieras al que te dé la gana que
no diga que me puse acuerdo por a quien
tú quieras camisa morada camisa morada
qué bonito nombre mira qué hacemos lado
yo voy a hacer así me dices ya cuando
quieras que me detenga es importante que
tú te fijes que yo me para donde quiera
y que no cambie la página diego narrar
que todos son distintas a menos que sea
un inicio capítulo algo así pues
cambiamos pero tú me dices ya cuando
tienes también
seguro no cambio mira lo voy a marcar
con el sobre para que no digan que yo
hablo con ustedes y luego trampa no si
hago trampa pero no ahora por eso digo
que se fije
vamos a vernos fíjate en la página
enseña un poquito por aquí para que vean
el número de páginas y lo tienen
y ahora quiero que la primera palabra
que sale y la primera palabrita sólo
anteriores y destruyó el cambiamos por
otros programas instituciones así está
señalada
la tienes no lo olvides y ahora necesito
tomar cuenta en un trance especial
también preparada
un poquito no tranquila para ti también
ahí vamos
estás en trance y qué tal
quería siempre por una foto mía pero la
gente se aburrió vamos a voltear te
tienes una palabra en tu mente la
recuerdas si tú tienes una predicción
abre la novela no veas tú nada ni
siquiera ver la pantalla no hagas trampa
como algunos iconos por ahí pues
romperlo y hay algo adentro es miren si
estuviera esto hay algo sin sacarlos
sacarlos pero el señaló no lo veas no lo
veas le voy a hacer a todo el mundo le
voy a decir algo hay dos tipos de magia
y yo lo voy a hacer todo el mismo tiempo
hay cosas que son poco probables pero
posibles y en cosas que son imposibles
lo que va a pasar ahora es poco probable
pero es posible
tú tienes una palabra que estás pensando
así dirá en el micrófono vemos alta qué
palabras estás pensando cuando queremos
de arte y ver lo que dice
eso es poco probable de tantas palabras
pero algunas veces no lo hacen mil veces
ahora viene la parte imposible está bien
recuerda porque hay gente claro ella me
señaló la palabra no se fijaron a quien
puede pensar vierte en un duendecillo
ahí dentro te manden whatsapp
rápidamente a los dos cuales cuando él
abrió un chaleco riendo pe si alguien
está pensando empezó el momento dejar
las drogas hay cosas
recuerda el número de la página ahora
viene la parte imposible busca la página
yo a distancia y quiero que veas la
palabra que te dé la gana no me la
señora a mi no digas nada la palabra que
te dé la gana la recuerdas recuerda
página
a buscarla que pasó no está la página
cómo no va a estar la página mujer
jabalina arrancó alguien la repare que
las tenía la mano no está en la página
pero cuál es la página 176
pero no es que
está arrancada se ve
yo dije que venía la parte imposible
tú tienes algo ahí ábrelo abre los si
esto llega a salir señores a cabo si hay
verdad que hay dentro de eso estoy
nervioso abro lo que hay
una página vaina acércate acércate que
no me queda cerca te venden con miguel
bein
el número que dice que el número dice
ahí lo ven ahí no se ve pero no importa
por tú si lo ves 175 dígame señores en
la que combina exactamente a qué
exactamente era que combina sí señor ha
diseñado muchísimas gracias
en francés
podéis bajar así lo mío
[Aplausos]
quieren ver más
vengan al otro test que ya se me acabó
el tiempo
muy buenas noches muchísimas gracias un
placer trabajar para ustedes
[Música]